yeah no they don't they don't but they
might dig right as though you know I
mean I think no I mean that wasn't a
great moment actually in terms of
girlfriend you know numbers that's no I
think I think women like men who do
interesting things I think that's I
think that you know we're lucky as men
that women are able to look beyond the
physical towards something else and I
think I think people I mean I I like it
in men too I like men who do interesting
things and I think that sense that
people have had a life that they that
they do something in the world at cetera
that that's that's interesting to me and
I mean I mean I'm gather it's
interesting to women as well